We're later going to talk about what might
have landed president Trump in the hospital
for an unscheduled visit.
And, um, we're going to talk about many of
the things in fact, which would likely have
caused stress over the weekend because quite
frankly, it was a very stressful couple of
days for Donald Trump during the second day
of the impeachment hearings on Friday with
Marie Evanovich close, uh, STO, uh, Roger
Stone, a close Trump advisor, Roger Stone
and close Trump ally Roger Stone was found
guilty on all seven counts with which he was
charged and Trump absolutely exploded afterwards.
Now as a reminder, please review my interview
with Roger Stone from, I guess it must be
about a year and a half ago at this point
or longer, where Roger Stone insisted he did
nothing wrong.
No one did anything wrong and it turns out
he may not have been honest with me during
that interview.
Check that out because Roger Stone was found
guilty on seven counts, including lying to
Congress, witness tampering, obstruction of
justice of the Russia probe into Donald Trump.
He is Trump aide and advisor number six to
be convicted.
So far.
So the immediate question is, how much time
might Roger Stone end up doing in prison?
The answer on paper is that he could end up
with up to 20 years.
Although if I had to bet, and I am not a betting
man, I would bet that Roger Stone gets nothing
close to 20 years.
And then of course we will talk about pardon,
uh, possibilities momentarily adding to the
hi-jinks of the stone guilty verdict.
There's this other Trump aide named Michael
Caputo who was in the courtroom at the time
of the verdicts readout.
And he had to be removed from the courtroom
because when the verdict was read, he just
turned around and turned his back on the jury.
Extraordinarily childish.
But again, these are the types of people that
Donald Trump has around him in a variety of
different capacities.
And then of course, Trump exploding on Twitter.
And why wouldn't he, if stone were to turn
on Trump, it could be very, very bad for the
president, although there's no indication
at this point in time that stone plans to
turn on Trump for the purposes of a lighter
sentence.
And why would he, if he expects or anticipates
that he will be pardoned by Donald Trump.
But we will get to that Trump first tweeting.
But, but, but, but what about all the people
that I want put in jail saying quote.
So they now convict Roger Stone of lying and
want to jail him for many years to come.
Well, what about crooked Hillary?
Comi struck Paige McKay, Brennan clapper shift
the shifts or, and Nelly steel and all of
the others, including even Mueller himself,
didn't they lie a double standard like never
seen before in the history of our country.
Understand that the president of the United
States is publicly saying he wants to, uh,
uh, put the legally appointed special counsel
who investigated him in prison.
Trump believes on the one hand, I guess that
Mueller wrote a report that completely exonerates
him.
Remember Trump went around the country claiming
that Robert Mueller completely exonerated
him.
But then he also wants the person who supposedly
exonerated him, imprisoned authoritarians
on one hand, but also a completely incoherent
on the other hand.
And then of course, you're still talking about
Hillary Donald.
Uh, seriously.
And notably it's important that Trump doesn't
actually say in the tweets, stone is innocent.
Stone is not guilty.
Stone might be innocent.
He merely says, if you convict Roger Stone
for this, then you should really convict all
of these other people that I don't like.
It's brazen.
Authoritarian.
What about ism?
Now let's discuss the pardon.
That's the other topic here that deserves
some attention.
Although it probably deserves its own exploration
in a topic in and of itself as usual, the
white house is not even entertaining.
The idea that Donald Trump may have signaled
in any direct or even indirect way that any
pardons would be incoming for anybody who
keeps their mouth shut.
Now we do have, when it came to Paul Manafort,
there were allegations that the possibility
of a pardon had been intimated through a number
of different channels.
I don't have anything specifically about Roger
Stone here, but we do know that if you keep
your mouth shut and you don't turn on Trump
and you don't turn into someone who could
potentially, uh, put Trump in a precarious
position, you may be rewarded with a pardon
when it is all said and done.
I hope that Robert Mueller truly deeply just
sincerely regrets not subpoening Donald Trump
and at least trying to force him to show up
in person because he didn't do it.
And Mueller is still getting crushed by Trump.
What was the big advantage again, to not bringing
Trump in?
I guess it was that Mueller said, well, the
policy of the justice department is not to
prosecute sitting president.
So we decided not even to subpoena Donald
Trump, arguably the weakest decision of Mueller's
entire investigation maybe of his entire career.
Because in the end he didn't do it.
He let Trump off and in the weakest possible
way.
And Trump is still saying publicly.
What about imprisoning Robert Mueller?
Pardon?
We will see Roger Stone sentencing not scheduled
until, I believe it's in the first week of
February.
And, uh, when that time comes, we will see
what the guy ends up with.
I think it will be far, far short of the 20
year maximum that he could hypothetically
be sentenced.
To.
Let me know what you think about the likely
sentencing for Roger Stone.